and of those four scripts how much
easier has it been for you to receive
feedback Oh
as far as criticism oh my god so much
easier the first script man I you know I
was like everybody else I mean I got my
I did exactly what I said earlier two
three pieces of coverage and you know I
was expecting them to come back
brilliant you know I was expecting them
to get the humor it had a lot of comedy
in it and you know one person liked it
they're all passes by the way they were
all passes and one person liked it the
other person was like I like this
character and I like this character and
one person just eviscerated it and I
pushed men you know like five days
obsessing over that one piece of
coverage going you know this son of a
doesn't get it he's got no sense
of humor he's an idiot
you know what would he know and you know
I went through that whole entire thing
and then I kind of sat there and won all
right
you know again all three people are
telling in certain instances and certain
spots all three people have told me the
same thing this character doesn't work
this character isn't you know growing
you know you're doing a great job with
your second this was actually one of the
pieces of feedback on the first one was
and you talk about growth earlier when
you have to kind of realize this you're
doing a great job with your secondary
characters your secondary characters
actually have all the growth but your
front year your lead character kind of
stays here and I went oh wait how is
that possible I've been talking I've
been thinking about this character for
like a year but then I had to go back
and look at it and go we'll wait a
second yeah right it's true everybody
else is kind of growing around him and
he is kind of watching them all evolve
and he's not really excited to go back
to the drawing board I had to say okay
well wait a second and that's when I
kind of wrote a little bit of an outline
for this character and said okay looked
at each scene individually and looked at
what he did in that particular scene
what his you know was he being proactive
it was he being passive which is a big
mistake that a lot of screenwriters make
you know things happen to their
characters as opposed to their
characters going out and doing things
which obviously is much more rewarding
and this character really wasn't doing
anything this character was kind of
weeding in and out of everybody else's
life
and things were happening to him and he
was moving forward or backward based on
kind of things that were happening to
him so you know it took me a while to
get there like I was very defensive are
you kidding me I was like how dare it
what the hell you and these people are
what the heck they're talking about like
who is this a Z I like to get the
initials of the guy to come in that's
cooked like that was this guy you know
bring him in front of me I was showing
what a screenplay is and yeah so you
know the second you know when I finally
got I took I took a lot of the lessons I
learned on the first script as far as
the coverage was concerned let me say I
didn't end up getting a lot of coverage
on that script because I kept rewriting
it because I wanted to get I wanted to
get positive feedback the next time not
that I was looking for recommends or
anything like that I just wanted to see
less criticisms and I'm getting less
criticisms I'm cleaning things up so a
lot of the criticism my criticisms I
kept getting back helped me not only
shape that script but inform the next
one because this is where you're not
like a you know again the example of
like in a primary character not moving
the story along it's the secondary
characters that are moving it on you
know that really carried over into my
second script I knew exactly where that
protagonist was going you know before I
wrote page one let's say you get a phone
call from another screenwriter that's
had an AZ go with a red pen over there
script yeah how are you gonna talk them
down from the ledge why we talk about
this all the time I'm fortunate it's
amazing because I'm even though I have
this one script and development and I
really have had nothing else made I do
get to speak at a lot of screenwriting
conferences and which is great and I
really enjoy doing it and but you get
that question often is like you know how
do you handle the criticism how do you
and I say you just have to be realistic
like you have to be you know you can't
be so precious about everything you have
to absorb it digest it and if you really
you know if you've said to yourself you
know I'm being as honest with myself as
humanly possible and I don't see this
then you gotta fight for it okay that's
okay but you you got to make sure you
really are being honest with yourself
and obviously that's easier said than
done because as writers you know we are
Precious about our material we do think
that it's you know works and you know
the other people just aren't getting it
it's it's you know it's easy to get to
that
you know with the endgame the script
that's in development right now you know
when I was working with David on things
that he wanted they were such minor
things that I felt like I was gonna you
know choke him you know at times because
it was like you want like it's like this
little thing but I get it like it's a
detail here and a detail there that
sometimes makes all the difference in
the world sometimes it's really really
big problems and sometimes it's really
really small little things and you have
to be receptive to both and you have to
be receptive to people's opinions
especially if they've climbed the
mountain you know I mean if they're if
the person that's giving you that
feedback has been to them top and back
and you're still climbing then you know
you got to surrender a little bit how
does that write or do a gut-check though
cuz baby they just they've been told by
mom dad and everybody back home and the
school play that they did that they're
amazing but then here is different and
there are people that will just
eviscerate you maybe they're not even
trying to be mean so how does someone do
that gut-check well hopefully they are
eviscerating you and they're not being
mean hopefully they're just being honest
and I think the way you do that gut
check is that your mother your brother
your sister your the your teacher your
the you know your fifth grade theater
teacher or whatever that you wrote the
great play about the tooth you know the
rotten tooth or something
what have they produced what have
they've done in this town okay what have
they done here okay they haven't done
anything here and if if that's what they
were looking to do then they should move
out here and do it it's fine listen you
always your friends and your family are
always there they're there for a
different kind of support they're there
to support you with your dream that you
want to be a working writer or that you
want to be a working creative in any you
know whatever the pursuit is that's
their job their job is to support you
and not say to you you're out of your
freakin mind don't pursue it but their
job is not to tell you that the script
is great okay it's the job of people who
are doing it to tell you what's right
and what's wrong about your work and if
you can accept that and again if you've
made the relationships what you're
getting in front of these people or if
you're paying for it with a you know
consulting or coverage from somebody
that's been there
then you have already put trust in
somebody with your dollars now you got
to put you know I'm gonna use a pun here
and I wasn't intending it but now you
got to do with your sense like you
really do I mean you really don't you
have to use your common sense and you
guys say you know this is this is why
I'm here
okay great material rise to the top you
do need a little bit of luck there's a
lot of things that go into being a
successful writer but if the content you
know whatever the luck is the luck is a
product of having you know the luck is
secondary is something that's going to
happen on the next level after you after
you produce the great content because
know it doesn't matter how much luck you
have and it gets in front of somebody
and they think it's garbage they're not
gonna you know and if it is garbage if
materials not there it's it's not so you
have to make sure it's the best that can
be and if you really want to be the best
that it can be you have to put your
trust into somebody or a couple of
somebodies so consider the messenger
definitely consider the messenger that's
your job to consider the messenger but
man if you're you know if you're lucky
enough let's say it's not even coverage
or a consultant if you're lucky enough
that somebody is passing your material
along to a producer with credits let's
say and that producer is you know
willing to come back to you and not just
say enough of me which you hear in this
town all the time but this producers
willing to come back and say it's not
for me but here's why it didn't work for
me and you're gonna if you're gonna be
defensive at that point and not be
receptive when you're getting something
from somebody who is making films then
shame on you you know I mean absolutely
shame on you so it's all about being
receptive and not being precious
you